all right well I am here with Robert
rice and once again amazing job out
there on the panel tonight Thank You
moms you enjoy yourself
I always enjoy myself what's what's not
to enjoy only on this show it really is
well bill is is beyond quick-witted but
it's also informative I think people get
a lot of information well thanks to
people like you and you are in this film
in equality for all
yes is this based on a book that you
it's based on a book I wrote called
aftershock the next economy in America's
future
and it is about why inequality is bad
for all of us and the definitely the
degree of inequality right now I mean
all almost all the economic games since
the end of the recession since the
recovery began mr. all the economic
gains have gone to the top 1%
meanwhile the typical household income
is going down so that the movie is not
an eat your spinach movie I mean it's
not kind of oh whoa I really want to
figure out about the economy know this
movie no it's entertaining we've made
funny people coming on the movies say
that they cried they laughed it's really
Jake Kornbluth the director and others
put together a movie that is I think it
grabs me
and people love it but it does talk
about this important issue of inequality
and the wealth gap that seems to be
growing you say a little bit of the
wealth gap is is the natural thing it's
oh of course I mean you know there's
gonna be some inequality there has to be
if you're gonna have the proper
incentives for people to work hard and
invest and innovate but we've got to a
point you know almost record level of
inequality where so much of the nation's
income and wealth is in the hands of a
relatively few number of people know the
four hundred richest Americans now have
more wealth than the bottom 150 million
of us put together
I mean you take the just the wal-mart
heirs themselves have more wealth than
30 percent of America at the bottom 30
percent of America so things are out of
control and it not only is hurting our
economy because the middle class doesn't
have the personal power to keep the
economy going but it is also hurting our
democracy
that much political power that comes
with great wealth you are inevitably
going to be corrupting and undermining
you're very optimistic guy do you see
this turning whether is this mystic a
catastrophe oh no I'm optimistic because
I'm that's how you know I'm I am a
student of American history I know that
every time capitalism has gone off the
rails we as Americans ideology aside and
we get on with what has to be done to
save capitalism from its own excesses
that's what we've done again and again
we save capitalism other countries you
know historically they've succumbed to
communism or fascism or whatever we
don't but we're getting very close to a
tipping point where we have to take them
reform actually all right well thank you
so much for coming back and dropping in
knowledge on us as you always do go
check out Roberts movie in equality for
all it's a fun time and we'll see you
soon
Robert rice thank you